hey what is that what is good welcome to
the players podcast Sims and left Co and
we are in a new studio our big time hey
feel I'm good how are you how you
feeling I just want to talk about the
table it's probably it's one of your
greatest achievements at bleach Airport
thank you I am being honest so if you're
watching on YouTube which if you're
listening to the podcast I highly
recommend that you go to the YouTube
channel and watch us talk about things
but also we're in a new room it's the
new podcast to do bleacher report and it
is completely blank and and dark on the
walls right now and that's not me and
the one thing that we want to do is send
us some stuff like I'm not asking for it
I'm not saying please send us stuff like
we're gonna decorate it but like other
podcasts are gonna be in this room and
I'd like Sims and left go stuff to be up
to so I'm just gonna say 16:33 Broadway
floor to say Sims and left go and send
us some stuff send them some stuff send
some stuff are we gonna have to cut that
out later
I think we're probably fine
16:33 Broadway we have to share the
studio cellar - there's like other
pockets like stick to football 48 first
48 with Howard back how dare they yeah
well I shouldn't be able to touch our
mics full 48 the first 48 would be
Howard Beck solving murder mystery you
mean the Howard Beck the NBA writer that
you just thought was 60 years old and
then he just happens to be like 10 years
covering the Celtics same as my dad
Howard back if you don't listen to this
I don't believe him Sims is a liar it
was off the record that never happened
so we've been getting so many people
tweeting at us and instagramming us the
last few days yes I can't stop saying
whoa big offseason
like people are DMing me and being like
it might hurt my relationship like my
girlfriend will be like Adam we have to
talk and then he'll go whoa so we're
gonna get - whoa big offseason later
we're gonna have phil simms the mascot
battle of the day Sims will be a ram and
I will be a Colt and I will be nothing
again so I'm just gonna continue being
undefeated in mascot
that's fine help judge it up I'd rather
not just participate I like to go nuts I
want to know and until I'm invited back
should we have three-way battle next
week yeah I don't even know if I want to
I'm one defeated left girl doesn't want
me to participate I'll just what kind of
noise as a Colt make noise Ram make
strong until I lower my head we got a
tweet that I want to read to you this is
from mr.c stirrer yesterday I was at a
restaurant with my eight-year-old son he
glanced at a shirt our server was
wearing and said mom look it Sims in
left go it was beavis and butt-head I
thought I should tell you it was amazing
have we realized that Sims and I kind of
mimic because we never have I just can't
believe this is all entirely fresh for
Chris every time we sit down to do a
podcast great that's great
and you know the more I'm in I'm slowly
dabbling here and there
whoa what does that mean looking at
comas my wife shows me stuff it's not
good you guys are sending me crap all
the show.i I do not like Twitter you're
against it I Twitter is Twitter is they
the hater verse of the world what's
making you say that I it's just nothing
but negative is your spot on it's it's
disgusting and I attribute it's almost
like it's like mean drivers on the road
because they never have to be held
accountable cuz we're I'm in a window
and you can't hear the mean disgusting
rude things on sank yeah
you can't put a face to it and Twitter
and it gives everybody this courage like
liquid courage like you're a drunk in a
bar and 16 awesome text you're just
making this based off the one day that
you and me scroll through your mentions
together or is this that was a bad day
for your mention oh yeah yeah I mean I
did see that but no it's been a number
of things whether it's it's just looking
at every whole thing Oh death is really
funny so I'm gonna skip ahead and we'll
come back on everything else but the big
story right now is the Sixers GM had
five Twitter accounts that were fake
where he would go on and badmouth
players and bad
off coaches and badmouth GM's I remember
with ray farmer and he had the cell
phone thing but do you think that a lot
of people in the NFL have Twitter
accounts like this like GM's or coaches
where they go on and either crap about
other people or talk to the media
coaches no definitely not does not go
NFL world there were they're worse than
me they don't even know how to use
Twitter or anything oh yeah so that now
GM's would they get in that
conversations like at Thomas to me
trough I'm not about that social media I
could see them doing I could see it too
I mean the crazy thing is I mean not
only this guy but we caught Kevin Durant
doing this laughter remember everybody
forgets that to where he's he was
sticking up for himself
I was wondering about the NFL yes the
MBA is so social media savvy and they
all have their accounts the NFL like
they're finally okay with highlights
being online a little bit I think
they're good I don't think you're gonna
have to change and I can play that game
I have a feeling that a lot of those
like the Washington GM or the guy that
was an indie that got fired like I could
see them like tweeting at reporters and
be like that was a good move actually
you know what I mean I yeah you're right
I mean you listen you can be political
that way and you can frame public
discussion a little bit was in doing
that certainly I I don't think that a
troll getting in someone's mentioned and
saying one thing that absolutely impacts
people's brains but the big question is
who did he tell he was doing this and
who ratted him out I'm not gonna get too
deep into it yeah that's a storyline
that a lot of people in Philadelphia are
liking right now huh Sam hinkie and we
will be talking because he was working
with the Broncos he did a little bit of
work with them but Sam hinkie has been
doing a lot of stuff in in a space of
artificial intelligence and apparently
one of the guys being connected to
solving this with Bryan Colangelo works
in artificial intelligence at a similar
company so we believe that it is Sam
hinkie 'he's revenge getting but i love
it
yes get rid of this guy get rid of him
I'm just curious to the NFL if you think
there's burner accounts yeah I
definitely don't think they're I mean we
saw Roger Goodell his wife had one yeah
ma'am
I mean that's again I don't know why
people worry about a bunch and I can see
my burner accounts iiiii here I'm sure
there's two weeks ago that the
second-youngest coach in the NFL didn't
understand the power of social media
until there was national news about his
son's name yes
so if Kyle Shanahan doesn't understand
it I mean sure when you're talking about
front office or GM's those guys are yes
they're speaking of Twitter there's
apparently an account that's started
today reasons big phil should host the
sims and left coach draft party that
pendrick and it's just giving reasons we
are not connected this is not a burner
account for us right we have no idea but
it says things like reasons reason
number four Phil Simms will be throwing
underhand reason number five Federer can
fill battling in ping-pong like it's I
still get DMS all the time about our
draft party it's gonna be great you got
to read reason number two what was it
what was to Deirdre gets a chance to
showcase her party planning skills on a
national stage Chris's sister this is a
Deirdre Burnham account imagine that she
really wants to have the party she does
speaking of the ping pong game that was
supposed to happen before the party Zach
won Fitzgerald DMV on Instagram and said
wanted to show love for the podcast
second I've watched Josh play ping pong
and I am confident big [ __ ] is gonna
whoop the floor with him Josh has no
power
he's the Alec Smith two big [ __ ] Pat
mahomes that's just it's just not a good
comparison I'll say that the Charlie
check this is not true online of me
playing ping pong or me against Cameron
who could barely hit the ball back to me
I had to I watched the tape it's true
I'm not I'm not making that up that's
rude
do not judge my ping-pong skills off of
how I looked against camera and that's
all I would say Cameron thanks people
I'm in trouble
I'm sure speaking by the way Cameron
who's definitely not our NBA analyst
correctly predicted the finals he
predicted the keeper today the Cavaliers
in the water that's why we hired him
that's incredible I know Zach he's
amazing what a guy I know
LeBron unbelievable ramen I was actually
rooting for Oh for one gentleman sweet I
think it might be for oh I don't think
he can even overcome this not Elise I
mean come on he could take the fourth
best player on the Warriors and he's the
second best player on his team we were
saying we were saying wits Nick Young
arguably would he be the third best
player on the cash he'd be close to him
it's amazing he I was hoping he would
score 70 the other night and they would
find a way to lose that's it's like our
Aaron Rodgers Russell Wilson the same
thing I have a lot in out of love
Cofield coming up later about Aaron
Rodgers I'm excited and I'm also sad
this might be a two hour podcast
oh great OBJ's contract I would like to
say thank you for guessing we were up to
over 300 guesses right now okay but here
are the people who did not get it right
Ryan Gauld
I'm sorry now here Chetta know rob turk
from portland oregon said go nine years
he predicted would be on May 28th not
gonna happen
Kyle's Anderson from The Woodlands Texas
no The Woodlands
Derek his comment was I forgot Simms was
a lefty what the hell he guessed May
31st which is what tomorrow so if they
get it tomorrow Alex Williams guest
tomorrow it also and said insider
information I'm hoping it doesn't come
on June 3rd David Barras Ford from the
United Kingdom guessed June 3rd and his
comment was Tebow is better than Sims
that's [ __ ] well he he didn't even
the Heisman yes he didn't course he won
the Heisman okay he's better than me
baseball all right so we usually talk
about Kyle Shanahan our favorite coach
but um since I know Kyle listens to the
podcast yeah Kyle you got to step it up
there really wasn't that good of news
about you and in fact you have
competition because now we have a new
segment called Gruden is grinding rooted
it's coming for your territory in the
Bay Area [ __ ] over [ __ ] okay
it's Johnny Gruden you're competing with
Sean McVeigh now Kyle and John Curtin
Rudin is grinding that and McVeigh is a
way cooler beard than you should have
first thing is rooting in car and I want
to ask you about your relationship with
Gruden car said I'm
with Gruden every morning he'll say
something to me at 5:30 and won't bring
it up the rest of the day then he'll
throw it to me at practice making sure
I'm still the top of the little thing he
gave me in the morning he just pushes me
and gets everything out of me and it's
been cool hmm is that a Gruden trick
that is a definitely a Gurdon trick yeah
you get that all the time all the time I
mean the amount of information he throws
at you on a daily basis it's all a test
it's all about to see what you can
retain could he fluster you during that
meaning to make you forget certain
things whatever it is I would love to be
in some of those meeting rooms again I
mean it gives me goosebumps and I think
about it at times because it's just
because I think it would sound awful but
you're right now kind of missing well
it's it's a it's one of those things
that yes when you're doing it at the
time it can be nerve-racking and all
those things but damn when you get done
with it and you look back at it you go
man I was the most alive I ever felt
when he told me to get up the board and
I was [ __ ] my pants going oh we
should I hope I remember this for me
shouldn't we haven't talked about this
formation in nine weeks so would he tell
you things at 5:30 in the morning and
then the whole day you're going I gotta
remember this because it's gonna come
later I gotta remember this like would
you plan that I wouldn't plan for it but
I just you knew when he was trying to
make points to go like this is something
we're gonna work on that yeah and just
the the looking at you or you know
whether he had a draw it on the board
and Circle it 12 times not only with the
the marker but then also point at it
with his red laser and circle at another
hundred times you can you could tell and
then you could always tell if he was
really passionate about a play or
certain things because then there would
always be the following video of stuff
to show about oh you know like it could
be simple [ __ ] so we watch Gruden camp
right that was the energy he took to
watching film with you go that wasn't
just for telling yeah it's more energy
when he's with you because he could
swear and really be crude and really
show you Jon Gruden
you know he could tell you some
perverted story whatever it may be that
there's just no rules to but yes that
was how meetings were there's how
meetings were when we got done with the
walkthrough in the morning right and an
NFL season like in Wednesday practice he
had like an 11 o'clock walkthrough it
was walked right back in the meeting
room
Gruden was gonna grill you on what
happened in the walkthrough have another
tape to show you stuff he wants to be
prepared for in the afternoon practice
practice would get over we'd go back in
the meeting room he'd be like purple cuz
he'd look he didn't put enough sunscreen
on so all his freckles had connected
that time at that point and we'd walk in
there and he'd be the same guy sweat
that style of coaching is not for every
player not for every player but you walk
in and like it I know we not everybody
can watch us but like he'd he'd have
like a left toe sweat on his forehead
listen if you will and he'd have his his
his visor it could be on backwards or it
was like suddenly to the side cuz he was
just sweaty and everything and he'd be
just sitting there like with his feet on
and he walked watching guys walk in the
locker room I mean walk in the
quarterback room look at the clock and
then somebody could've cause we got it's
about [ __ ] time you got in here and
start this [ __ ] meeting is he one of
those special guys that can see people
look at the clock and remember that yes
he said he's gonna he is it does have a
special brain he has a brilliant brain
yes he would be what you would call I
like how his brain works yes so there
here's a story - about Gruden why I love
him and why I'm afraid of this season
for him in the 10-year contract hundred
million dollars they gave him by the way
I was in Vegas this past weekend and I
drove by where the Raider stadium is
gonna be it's like right there it's
gonna be wild
yeah stations at the seats Nick in the
back everybody we're gonna call my dad
at 4:15 he would like you to call in the
house phone who the house phone that's
live producing here's what I love about
Garuda and what scares me
Gruden is on a conference call with
Raiders season ticket holders and he
says last time I was in Oakland we stole
Rich Gannon from Kansas City we took
Andre Rison from Kansas City we took
Albert Lewis from the Chiefs we love
stealing from the cheese so now we got
Derek Johnson and I'm on my way to the
Raiders store to pick up a Derek Johnson
Raiders Jersey and I'm gonna wear it
home tonight I love that so him that's
what I love about Gruden that he they
signed Derek Johnson and - season ticket
holders he goes I love stealing things
from them like he's a coach that
embraces robberies love them
what's a pic he wants hate he fuel that
of hate he's gonna pick the fight Kansas
City so when it comes time the week at
Kansas City he already hates him here's
what I cares me about Jon guru yeah he
followed it up with well we feel like
the middle of our defenses solidified
big-time now Derrick Johnson all-time
leading tackler and Kansas each Chief
history started every game for them last
year they were the division champs and I
go Derrick Johnson hasn't been a good
middle end of constantly Chris since he
hasn't been active like ready for this
type of football like two three years
like he was a liability in these last
few years he wasn't a liability he was
the same guy we used to be yes I know
that yes you're right about that that's
what I look at his offseason and I go oh
[ __ ] he's signing the Jordy Nelson's
he's excited about the Marshawn Lynch's
yeah he's like all the guys where I go
I'm worried that that all of them are
gonna be able to have a whole year of
success and he it's the guys that he
interviewed on Monday Night Football
that he's excited he's excited about his
the ones that a little old in the tooth
that's my concern
i I and your concerns are real it was a
concern for me when we played in Tampa
we used to complain in the locker room
because we'd go damn we never signed
young free agents or we never have draft
young guys to fill in our roster needs
they'll be good early right they'll be a
veteran exactly but like weeks 12
through 16 yes let's see if you have
legs he'll build the team the right way
I think as a whole but yes this year I
do think he's you know erred on those
type of guys because he wants to set the
culture he wants everybody to get his
system he didn't want mental mistakes
those things that can break our message
so yes it's fine
hey set the tone you're right it's kind
of like your first class as a college
coach right Jerry Nelson he's gonna be
on the front of the line this is how you
run this route look he did it perfect
now you should too that's what he's
doing and then it does make sense but I
do think he I would think that would be
something he learned from that just know
that yeah for the future Raiders it
can't always be the nine-year veteran
let's hold them over for one year that's
why that relationship him and Mackenzie
is so big yes he needs to give because
Mackenzie apparently drafted art and key
and a few of the other ones that were a
better risk right I do feel bad that
we're not letting Kyle kind of like have
the shine
got outshine by girls make some news
yeah I got I got let's talk to him yeah
let's give the Sims advice to Kyle
Shanahan apparently someone commented in
an Instagram post to Dez Bryant what
team do you want to play for he
responded with the Niners yes and then
deleted it right everybody wants to play
for Kyle of course but shakaal want Dez
Bryant no okay
no here at all Kyle no yeah sorry Kyle
don't sign them like you don't think
he'd be a good fit him and uh I think
they are Garcon kind of work in the
middle I keep whispering just to keep
this I think piers the same guy
basically just young age and really
probably a little bit better a route
runner and of course understands Kyle's
offense already see that's what's heard
gonna hurt Dez the thing we said
originally right the fact that he's been
in Dallas his whole life and he really
had enough never do anything except line
outside the one side of the ball slam
sir go right he never really had to do
some of the slot stuff they're reading
the routes reading the coverage and I
think where a lot of teams would love it
Dez Bryant as your third receiver those
are the kind of things you want to do
your third receiver and you haven't seen
him do it and as we talked about and
then felt coaches are so conservative by
nature yeah I gotta see it on film 20
times to realize he can really do it so
I get that and yeah Kyle I don't think I
don't think it's a area of need for Kyle
in that offense right now I think they
need defense they do it's funny you're
Toma everybody wants to play for Kyle
yeah Cassius marshes on the Niners and
he came out yet another guy that comes
out and says the Patriots don't have fun
they're no fun to play with and I'm so
happy to be in San Francisco it's it
seems like everybody that didn't have
fun in New England's just coming out and
bash in the Patriots the summer be it is
it's why the Eagles started I think
Brady and Grogg started it I think that
started the pie line - I mean listen
Belichick it's a tough place to work
play whatever it is he holds your feet
under the fire for every nickel he gives
you and you know there's players up
there that we've talked about they're
mad about the Super Bowl and they're
taking their little shots of them right
now for the first time ever isn't it
worth trading fun to win Super Bowls
that'd be miserable in a year like if
I'm a football player see that mate this
is the thing I'm definitely not a
football player but I think if we were
coming
a Patriots Super Bowl that's a great
argument but the Eagles who probably
were the loosest team in the NFL beat
them so you don't have to be that way
that's what we've always said about Bill
Belichick is you can't argue with a man
that has five Super Bowls because he's
always right well when you beat them
then you do we don't have to do it your
way just because the Eagles win the
Super Bowl one year is not an indictment
on how Bill Belichick runs the
organization no I'm just saying they're
in it every year no it's like yeah this
is the price of doing business in
England Josh I think what you're saying
is right this is where I would defend
New England it's brutal
it's I mean coaches have left their
front office people left there and you
walk out the bill you go yeah I mean
that's literally how I felt my last day
keeper but yet it is a special place to
work but yes you know it's you say the
statement is a damn camp okay would you
say the statements correct yeah I want
my players and my teams to be operated
the ones that I watch and care about
like the Patriots but if I was playing I
would probably rather win somewhere else
like since I don't have to go through
that like you said Josh I want my team
executing at that type of level because
that's it's like a fantasy team then
like this is great best chance to win
but actually doing it yourself who I
want to be a marine I don't want to go
through the the work like the workouts
all that and everything to do the
training right I'm not capable of that
marine right oh yeah but that's what
separates me from the Marine yeah the
place okay your reward is what you said
Josh right you go there and yeah you're
not gonna have fun there's not gonna be
a bowling day in the middle of training
camp there's not gonna be a water
balloon fight no some ice cream man
swing by that's always not need a grind
every day so yes there is not a lot of
fun that goes on in New England but the
fun is the ring ceremony the fun is
celebrating after the AFC Championship
game the fun is being able to show your
family for years and years after this
hey look I got five rings [ __ ] all you
else like [ __ ] everybody else I gots a
weird thing to save your family
but I'm saying the people that are
saying no fun but as a player of course
you would like to be at a place yeah
that's a little more lighthearted and
and can be fun that way and that's why
you've seen some players go up there and
disappear from Earth because like New
England can be the killer of fun and
guys like Chad Ochocinco they wanted to
smile a few times a day
wayde's Worth Reggie Wayne ad aliased
Thomas there's a plenty of personalities
that have gone up there and that's been
the end of their career
yeah because talked about it yes because
because a lot of guys they they feed
from their own personality about how
they perform on the field and when you
make them a robot off the field and they
go become robots on the field I'm
curious the the McCourty twins would be
the perfect twin test where you have one
McCourty that's been with them forever
and one recorder that's not and you just
test their personalities based on like
it's like a say if Devon is incapable of
having fun you play a board game with
that you realize that Devon never
suggests fun topics guys what should we
do Devon's like our taxes Devon sit down
please
but apparently bail checks a little bit
of fun there's a little video going
around today of Bill Belichick going
through the drive-thru of chick-fil-a
does not look happy I think he sees the
cameraman in the distance but my only
question for you would be do you think
he goes for the fresh-squeezed lemonade
or the hand-spun milkshake that's an
easy answer that's the big debate at
chickpeas the answer I think he's a
spicy chicken fresh squeezed lemonade
with pickles with pickles that sort of
chicken sandwich I don't know the fact
that he's going to the chick-fil-a
drive-through tells me he might be
Sheikh sneaking a shake in there
that'd be that the easy that before he
gets to the office after right when he's
left the nutritionist who's been
watching over him he has a nutritionist
the nutritionist the year I was there
was taking very into account of what
taught he was definitely Bill was one of
his players imagine the nutritionist be
like Bill like he has to discipline bill
we need to talk I saw that on Instagram
you've seen you yourself with your shirt
no man who suggests the t b12 diet
without knowing I well I think though
it's so funny when I was looking at the
menu of fresh-squeezed lemonade
hand-spun milkshake why is it when
there's an action associated with a
it sounds more delicious ate our cooked
ribs
you're right slowly cooks slow roasted
baked beans like if it was just baked
beans I'd be like hope they don't cook
them fast
I hate those fast roasted big it just
speaks to how fat we are as a country
Bella checks don't check a fast food guy
not that I know of what if this outed
like what if his new wife and his
nutritionist like this causes a big cut
so they caught him with like a live TV
camera caught him
no no just like a somebody a worker on
their phone bill was coming so he must
maybe he's a regular here this is by the
way a part of our of our beautiful
segments beans not beef we're a podcast
that once you'd eat healthier yes
because it's important limit your red
feed intake beans not be funny you
should say that Charles clay is gone on
a diet why because he recently had a
knee injury and he just kind of
reevaluated everything and he went on a
diet he tried to go vegan oh yeah lasted
for a month count it was good but it was
hard and it was too expensive his diet
is now devoid of sugar his meals include
chicken and fish but little if any red
meat good I'm trying to keep as much
inflammation out of my body clay said I
feel awesome right now beans and beef
charles clays on the bean sounds like a
winner Theo Riddick vegan and not adrian
peterson vegan two different things yes
sounds like bowel checks going adrian
peterson vegan just stopped off at
chick-fil-a left coast coaching
impersonations have not good cam is
amazing about cam is good we should get
cam in here one time we should just do
balichek that's the next level of the
pocket ham but he's got xual voice
actors he's got like me and my agent
that's the same voice I don't check in
my agent or the same guy I what do you
want to do nothing
dad take brain Sims yeah that's always
interested to hear the beans not beef
thing that was cool the Charles clay
yeah alright now it's time for the next
segment legs and ass yes baby
I like this
first one a Leonard fournette quarterly
down to 220 here is a picture I'm gonna
spill that of Leonard Neverland right
now my question about Leonard fournette
at 220 is that a good thing
it's know when your chiseled out of rock
it doesn't matter well I just so he
meant to the combine number at like 240
and then like you're something he was
like wait like 228 right my question for
you is what weight do you want to see
Leonard Fernanda mmm I think Leonard
fournette I think the weight we saw he
was around like 230 I think he was
telling people like toward the
mid-season last year I think and
remember a few quotes I would say around
there is going to be the right he's the
type of guy that's probably us to starve
himself to be 220 he just could he's
gonna gain more weight as the season
goes on as he starts to work out looks
at weights and he gets five pounds
stronger remember he like turned all of
his trophies into weight as local high
school he's insane
oh wait so Leonard fournette you'd
rather him start lean and work on speed
agility quickness in really good shape
and it'll still work right because build
it from a core of okay we're stripping
you down let's start from there you're
healthy now you could put on the right
amount of muscle to to go back to to 28
to 30 whatever it may be running backs
are freaks man I mean it doesn't matter
if he loses weight like I promised you
Leonard fournette goes into the gym for
two weeks every other day he can be 240
and jacked in no time and he is there
like the freakiest people on the planet
destroys muscles before we move on can
we just explain we've had a lot of new
listeners come to the podcast can we
explain where legs and ass comes from
how that became a thing legs and ass is
it's part of our Constitution I can't
remember which Amendment but it just
simply simply states that the best
players the NFL typically have a
beautiful set of legs and ass and it's
what Chris Sims looks for when he's
evaluating a talent favored got big
hands great houses legs and ass legs and
online oh you could push 400 pounds
how's your legs and ass I guess it's
weird its football did you guys see the
pictures of say Kwan throwing out the
first pitch
here is the sound legs ass on back here
is the sound of sake Juan going out to
the mound and listen to the baseball
announcers not be able to handle
themselves
[Applause]
it's all in the legs Paul check out the
legs I know what that he's got a set on
him look at those he's a thick fella I'd
rather try to hit him to tackle it but
what's so funny is he literally couldn't
hold it in I'm telling you that I've
never seen a body part take over an
offseason like say Kwan's legs are
taking over this offseason yeah the golf
picture throwing out the baseball the
pictures online are insane his hamstring
is another body part not since Takeo
Spikes neck have I seen people get
mesmerised by a body part no it's
Jackson season it's Bo Jackson [ __ ] I
mean that's what it is when I look at it
like that's it's that kind of legs and
body you're just like whoa what's funny
now though is like with Instagram and
stuff people are just only focusing like
we there should be an account just
called sake Juan's legs say it's one the
offseason I've never seen a rookie win
over confidence because of just a body
part it's um he's the man legs and ass
and back I mean those are the things you
look at for any great athlete and don't
always take NBA players into that
because NBA players are their own type
of animal then they're in my own ways
because they're longer it's more about
one girl I've never seen a human being
like Kevin Durant before that's what I
mean but it's not power based so it's a
little different like like Michael
Jordan wasn't the best dunker cuz he had
great hamstrings and ass no baby because
he had an Achilles tendon that was like
three feet long and had a huge femur
bone it's a great-looking cinco's leg
you realize that his calf muscle was
like a golf ball at his knee right and
you're like oh that's how physics but
this kid is like can have an
unbelievable vertical because he can
literally go I'm gonna squat my ass down
and explode up into the air and I'm
gonna jump 40 inch vertical I think
what's funny we're talking about Leonard
fournette
when Leonard fournette excuse me when
Derrick Henry stood next to Mark Ingram
everybody lost their minds of that
championship game but then when you see
Derrick Henry in person you realized
that his waist is at our chest and he's
got long legs and they're they're not
that meaty okay Leonard fournette was
supposed to be like the physical guy
that came in that we went this guy I've
never seen anyone built like him say
Quan has erased all of them from our
memory he has it's he's the best bill
athlete coming to the NFL
I mean like Garrett miles Garrett like
those are the two guys and I think in
the last 5-10 years that are the most
incredible appearance yes yes that just
wowed you and his body's upper body I
mean you see those pictures - he's
chiseled I mean he's do you want to do
an all legs and ass team sure so that
every position we go through and we pick
this team right off the bat like all
legs it's gonna be the better players
that's it's not going to be as exciting
as people think because right away I'm
going
Kalil max on it Aaron Donald's on it or
not it's definitely know what I mean
Fletcher Cox is probably on it you know
you start to go through it it's not as
hard as you think is I mean he's got
some legs and ass - yeah I mean just
quarterback you putting on this much
quarterback with legs and ass that's a
good one actually I mean my mind went to
cams and went up the cam right right off
the bat for sure but there's somebody
else were missing I think all right just
oh I know who it is I think I think I'm
pretty safe and sane so Wilson dak
Prescott or Russell Wilson would be the
two guys definitely inner thigh rubbage
yes agreed don't wear generally do wear
spandex when you swim in the ocean
because I would like to get people's
rosters whether they want to do it on
reddit or on Twitter or Instagram who
would you include in your all legs and
ass team and if you'd like to suggest
names that have not been mentioned here
please do these provide photo evidence
Yeah right this is not a metric this is
not analytics like look at guys like say
Quan Khalil Mack Lawrence Taylor Reggie
white whatever back in the day that's
the kind of legs and ass we're looking
for to fill out this team Phil Simms
good man he's got some legs and a squat
holy cow you look at pictures of Phil
from that era
two other quarterbacks they look like
children and Phil looks like an h-back
you should we should ask big Phil about
like Dan Marino asking them about
lifting weights before the game one year
they played in 93 and I apparently leave
it for the okay I was like realize how
thick and strong my dad was on the field
that day for some reason what are you
doing yeah he's like I mean so this with
wait thing help you I was watching clips
of Dan Marino this weekend for some
reason huh Dan Marino when he threw it
deep ball it was just like it was a
laser like it never got above a certain
height like Aaron Rodgers when he throws
the helmet launch it up I think Dan
Marino would ever do that
no it would just be like yeah Dan was
the kind of guy that like a quarterback
challenges couldn't throw it really past
like 58 yards right it's just it's
literally hovering above it just wasn't
the motion that led to launching balls
you got anything like 40 or below he
could literally throw it four feet off
the ground it's a little Phillip Rivers
ish just like this I hear especially it
towards the end of his career early on
like 84 losing the Super Bowl all those
it was a little more of a real throw all
right so it's time for whoa whoa big
offseason holy offseason and we have a
lot in backup quarterbacks
that are actually hidden legends and
this is when we uncover them first one
up Teddy Bridgewater
there's legitimate buzz be careful
because this buzz is legitimate that's
right Oh TAS are going on and
Bridgewater's created legitimate buzz he
could end up starting for the Jets but
more importantly that trade value is
trending up guy rocketing whoa big
offseason big offseason legitimate buzz
you find that by the buzz I am buying
the bus I am yes I mean I know a little
bit about it too so yeah I think the
buzz is real I think he's opened up so
tell us what you're hearing well I just
I've heard just good reviews I'm not
gonna sit here and tell you that it's
been like you know anything specific but
that he's physically farther along than
they were expecting and picked up the
offense very quickly what happens I
always want to know what were they
expecting yeah I know well it was dicey
I think I think they might feel like
they're like our expect if he hits the
field we're happy and then like he's
throwing there like he's excited I got
the feeling yeah maybe they were like
slightly duped and signing him at first
especially when like Teddy came out and
said I'm not comfortable talking about
when I'll practice right so to me I
think the other thing is that's
interesting yeah is does he continue to
do well if he does well in the preseason
games what happens because I'm pretty
sure and we need to look this up I think
Josh McCown he's got ten million dollars
right I think it's guaranteed there's
nothing they can do with Josh but do
they make Ted teddy bridgewater trade
bait at some point if he has the first
two preseason games that are awesome
whatever it may be because we're at a
point now no trade is gonna happen in
the next month no yeah everyone's
evaluating their team they're going
through it's if injuries happen in
training camp or if there's injuries in
the preseason game or someone gets out
there in live action and completely
bombs and Teddy goes to one of the teams
I would imagine with a rookie or an
opening or you know it's a 14 that's
like really in desperate need of a
backup like maybe let's just say New
England maybe New England and we can't
have Brian who's our backup right but I
know it's not gonna happen in the
division AFC East the Jets aren't gonna
trade them but the situation like that
it is guaranteed to no it is right so
he's there yeah all right but legitimate
Buzz next one whoa big offseason I've
never seen anyone like him no we're not
talking about Von Miller or Miles
Garrett no or not talking abouts they go
on Berkeley we're talking about backup
quarterback for the Saints taste some
Hill whoa I've never seen anyone like
him Joe Lombardi when the offensive
coordinators down there said you see
Aaron Rodgers and those kind of guy the
fact that he's mentioning Aaron Rodgers
when describing taste Mills incredible
yes you see those guys they make plays
just ability to avoid the rush this guy
runs a sub for 5:14 he's strong he might
be the strongest guy on the team the
reporter followed up with are you
serious and he goes certainly pound for
pound he might be the strongest squatter
the guy is a freak athlete I've never
seen anyone like him at this position
it's probably because he was running
gunner last year and he's probably not a
quarterback no you've never seen it was
why he ran like for 300 yards a game and
BYU a few times whatever it may be so I
got a seat anyone like I gotta see more
of this kid first just to play the
quarterback position I mean as an
athlete it is impressive when you watch
no it's it's legit lettuce ISM I just
the football right I need to see it I
gotta see if is it natural is it natural
within him to play the position the
right way that's what that's the Sims
test yes I have a pattern people are
always like this are always great in
OTAs in the start
it's oh it's scramble around you know
fire drill and you know everyone will go
this drove me crazy at times with Jon
Gruden because he used to do this with
Jeff Garcia I was like it's seven on
seven and he's scrambling around and
you're there's nobody rushing him and
you're giving them props for throwing
incompletion I didn't even know we could
do that okay I'll start doing that too
oh yeah big offseason seven-on-seven
scrambling yes I didn't even know that
was possible until Jeff Garcia got to
our team
I really didn't nobody ever did it and
then he did it and Gruden was like what
did go man that's gonna play geez guys
granted I was like well I didn't know
we're gonna do that every time we didn't
make a decision when I did it
you were like [ __ ] throw the ball
make a decision I didn't know how to
rather dance around for nine minutes
without a pass Russian why is he
scrambling I don't know he's from nobody
got open there's no one to throw do so
if I run tomorrow actually it's your
thing right because it does teach
receivers scramble drills and all those
things so there really is value to it it
just pissed me off at the time well yeah
I wanted to be like him he's giving him
credit you didn't tell us we could ever
do that until now I was framing it to be
Garcia to be the starting quarter
you know that there's an MVP a future
MVP the NFL on one of these teams that's
right not only he's not a
second-stringer he's a third stringer
Mac Holland's for the Philadelphia
Eagles we have one quarterback who
should have been the MVP Carson Wentz
one who was the Super Bowl MVP Nick
Foles
and one who could potentially be an MVP
that's right he's talking about Nate's
son felt oh the third string quarterback
that came over from the Washington
Redskins I just lost you at Nate's son
fans Matt Colin says he's sticking with
the claim because of what he saw in
practice last season I'm sticking with
the clay because I play xbox with them
every day after practice so I can't back
off of it now you didn't think that Nate
said felt could be the MVP after that
incredible week 16 show against the
Dallas Cowboys negative ghostrider this
is when this is when friendship
overtakes evaluation in Atlanta FL
locker room son fell though with the
all-time response showing that he's a
gamer I just show up and I do what they
tell me to do
I don't peek out how many reps I'm
getting for the day I know I need to be
ready to play if you try to read scripts
it's not playing the game
because then when you're playing the
game you do what coach calls in the
headset I'm working everyday to work on
my craft hey I'm sure he is for MVP
Nate's I liked his brother a lot I know
Nate's a good dude but if he was the
future MVP oh yeah the Washington
Redskins wouldn't have let him go whoa
big truth you're hearing big things
though about Josh ow Josh Allen yeah I
had a member of the media up there at
first tell me and then I talked to you
know somebody involved in their
organization Josh Allen's blowing people
away
I mean blowing people away I know to the
feel like it's like sounds like it's
ours super well it sounds like a almost
you know a carson wentz thing it's just
not only I think everybody's blown away
by the mental approach but practice is
eye-opening like we said it would be
yeah it's I it's not surprising it's not
surprising to read too much into this
because if there's any guy that's gonna
inspire people after OTAs throwing and I
know there's been pushed back up there
in Buffalo about them drafting him a
little bit like this guide the 56% I
know I know this is gonna happen it's
gonna roll out with his like Clydesdale
legs and throw a 70 yard bomb in the air
and they're gonna go man he can actually
see over the line we haven't had a
quarterback that could do that in years
Oh AJ McCarron's going into the room be
like he wasn't that great McCarron talk
[ __ ] like it's the part like AJ
McCarron's average ass and Josh Allen
throwing bombs is the perfect
combination for the whoa big offseason
soup here right can you finish your
scouting report on what you want that no
that was basically left go just took
that over I would like to hear what's
going on with Josh and Bello def go he
can't control himself
they're just blown away it's the coaches
the players everybody it's it's one of
those type of things again where I've
thought about Carson Wentz when I first
heard it because those are the things I
heard in Philadelphia and I can remember
Fletcher Cox actually telling my dad
like no no when Carson's out there we
kind of the defense kind of gets up and
watches them because we're always like
damn that was unbelievable I'm hearing
those same type of things from Josh Alan
it's wowing at all levels or anything
about the tweets that's over
he's the corner I haven't heard anything
about the tweets nope I haven't I mean
that's gonna be for players in the
locker room to judge to see if there's a
crack in the armor does he say something
that's a little questionable you know
there's
leeway in a locker room guys don't I
mean listen to Richie incognito can make
it through a locker one that a lot of
guys can they're not it's not a to
political of an environment but if you
repeatedly show signs of racism or just
idiotic things then you're gonna start
to lose the locker room all right we
still have players contracts coming up
we are going to be doing a nice out of
left go field and I have a few Blake
bortles stuff to get to well yeah buckle
your face but first let's call big Phil
let's get him on here Sims what do you
think about this crazy push a tea Drake
battle that's going on right now
Oh push a tea and Drake yeah I just knew
push a tea I only think I knew about
Pusha T is Kanye buying that Whitney
Houston picture for his record yeah well
I think it's going on between Drake and
push the tea right now I have no idea of
what's going it's literally one of the
most intense Rap Battles push the last
20 years okay let me just make sure I
got this right push 40 used to be like
him and his brother right yeah all right
clips Yeah right right
I remember them I met at the airport
once and we talked they were cool but
Drake is the man yeah that was the song
you Drake is alone what's going on oh my
god you doing okay
I'm doing well film well what do you
think about this Drake push a tee beef
right now the what this battle between
Drake and push a tee it's crazy I have
no idea what you're talking don't feed
into his games father what do you think
it is
he knows who Drake is Drake's the rapper
dad you see if the other one
push it - you're not gonna know him no
of course not no he's trying to be all
Gianni millennial on you oh my god
that's so cool you know we got to get
you over here to house beat your ass and
a few things yes get to back down to
earth I think it would be in our line
don't see a man and he's a Malena you
what about this battle
man yeah you know what let's see we'll
play a little hoops okay what else
whatever else you can do if we're gonna
play this challenging me and Josh and
things but I'm curious
let's go sweating as we're talking so if
we play basketball we have that IV
machine there did you see the scouting
report video that was sent your way oh
my god
all right so Josh doesn't know this but
we've sent footage of Josh playing
ping-pong to big Phil big Phil what do
you think about your future opponent
wait I just want to know this it's just
Josh there I'm here yes okay Josh Joshua
is a white guy in that video this is a
no kidding okay I thought the other guy
was Josh but Josh what amount of effort
were you putting into the game were you
just casually playing or were you
playing scale of 1 to 10 I was at a1 oh
gosh you're like a3 me I mean maybe to
you just oh you just were you were
letting him tag along I was just trying
to get a little rally going with them I
didn't want it to be a shutout Phil what
was your takeaway I want to shut him out
man you have a chance to crush somebody
go for it
Cam Ranh he was at the office I was
trying to have a little fun with them I
don't want to do this guy this guy
doesn't have the killer instinct dad I
like your chances I don't know what kind
of battle was I actually played
ping-pong today and yeah yep you know
you playing against I played against my
daughter she's pretty good it's good she
beat you know she would listen you would
be dead last in this house under
competition except I will give you an
edge against some of the grandchildren I
would hope against Phillip I don't know
if I would like my chances all I'm gonna
say is whenever we do end up playing
ping-pong I want a full line of Sims
waiting for me and I'm just gonna run
through you all will get the cousins up
from Kentucky
I'll play the sisters the grandchildren
everyone before we even start yeah never
played anybody of course as good as me
but what I say I talk
man I won't I talked serious trash this
is what I'm this is my dad doesn't I
don't think dad wants to do this at the
draft party in front of everybody
because he can't be he wants the mess
made crew that's what's crazy is big
Phil like our fans all they say is that
when you give it to fend rickettes their
most fun ever like Rick would be I am
let's I talk just like golf are you know
and golf but you can't talk and you know
I used to play when I used to play a lot
of I was a pretty good player and we'd
be on the first hole when I was playing
somebody who I didn't really know and of
course I know here's the whole objective
is gonna be so I'm gonna beat Phil and
he'll I have a 5-foot putt and he'll
miss and I said man don't worry about it
you know you have no chance of winning
so just relax enjoy the day and you know
you're not gonna beat me and but it
doesn't matter because I'm not gonna see
you for maybe five you you could go home
and he'll all your friends whatever
whatever story you want you could lie
and tell him you beat me and they all a
couple guys I did two just went well
you're right I said yeah just to enjoy
the day take your beating like a man and
to be oh it don't worry about it's not
gonna win I welcome the chatter you can
talk all you want it goes in one ear out
the other
yeah you're saying it now but you you
play against amateurs you have no idea
yeah you know but I will say this here
I'm giving you all this and there's my
son my oldest son one superb yes I watch
him on TV in the mornings and they have
these contests and these drafts and all
this stuff I mean I'm just gonna you're
you're the Washington Wizards
Christopher hell I mean you just get
your ass whooped every day I mean I
understand the judges a little impartial
yes but they don't the worst picks yeah
you just gotta just you gotta win so
convincingly that you know there's no
doubt so I don't know I know but yeah I
can't wait in the public you are you
doing this on purpose so you know to
keep the job tell me that you're doing
that that you're trying to be nice
what's he talking about
even it is no good when Christos purple
tonight they'll be like build the
perfect team of quarterbacks and then
like Florio picks like the ones that
like Wikipedia would say are the best
quarterbacks and then Chris picks the
actual best quarterbacks so I feel you
just don't get fill hole I heard a story
that Chris was saying earlier that Dan
Marino was shocked that you worked out I
told him and maybe I'm wrong with this
story but wasn't it before the 93 game
you're down there pregame warmups right
you're gonna play the Dolphins
and Dan Marino started asking you about
weight lifting could've been yeah I
can't quite remember but go ahead okay
you were warming up if I remember the
story correctly and then Dan Marino and
some other quarterback coach are sitting
over there I guess marveling at your you
know legs and ass and the fact that you
had guns as a quarterback and I thought
you I thought at least I remember you
saying or telling the story as in like
Dan was acting like wait so wait this
weightlifting stuff really helps you is
it help you throw the ball to so maybe
I'm wrong but I'm not gonna get I think
that was at the time Dan was going to
like he might have had the torn Achilles
that year maybe I'm not sure what was
the game it was a really big deal right
and I was really disappointed he was
hurt because the Giants had more fans
there than the Dolphins did right so
that you know I took the field I was
like damn this is better than being in
Giants Stadium and of course as always
told you throw the football down in
Miami that's cheating yeah and I mean
come on
I can't grip and throw the ball down
there in a humidity in it
man I don't care if it's pouring rain I
played the pouring rain down there once
and was going this is even easy in Tampa
you did what's that yeah Tampa I think
it was pouring rain once an you know a
preseason game I played in pouring rain
in Miami and I was like oh my god you're
not gonna play in the right and I'm dad
as always like Joe
he's like Joe it's just well anybody is
from the Northeast well when you're in
the Northeast and like you're gonna be
Tom Brady or Phil Simms or any of those
quarterbacks and throw in some of these
weather situations and these stadiums up
here you know you look at the guys in
South Florida and you watch it a
highlight of their game to go damn it's
75 and there's now
please Eli play-doh whale I played
really well in the rain in Tampa last
year he did that's funny yeah well you
know the weather pattern has changed
this really has I'm not given to all in
the old days no it's too like January I
mean some years I'd go I'll take a
twenty mile an hour wind today I'd be
happy with that
yeah and it I told you this story I
don't know I guess I'm in Eli said about
his fourth or fifth year and I'm doing
one of their games and I said you know
something I said well what about the win
is that a big deal for you you lied he
goes honey singers you know I don't
think I've ever played a windy game yet
and I just spent what yeah and so it
really has changed its completely I mean
we see games in Green Bay now where it's
still beautiful in December and
everything so how we got started on that
but oh I know what it was yeah so Dan
Marino and I that all season with Marc
rippin and John Elway were playing golf
down in Miami
and some in fact we were playing with
Tiger Woods right and uh this is before
the Honda Classic and Tiger was 18 years
old playing as an amateur gonna play in
it you know so you know he musta thought
we were crazy the way we were talking
and you know basically somebody's
getting ready to hit it you'd say
something and you'd hit it and you go
wow you could imagine how foul we were
right and Tiger Woods actually told the
story once he goes I just couldn't
believe how hard they rode each other
constant and but we're playing and Dan
said something where we play you guys
this year I said yeah I know you know
we're gonna win and he got really upset
what do you mean you know you're gonna
win I mean I should tell you the Miami
Dolphins there's no way no the Miami
Dolphins can't beat the New York giant I
mean we're just too tough for you guys
and I said it for real yes were you were
you he got all bared up I mean for
anything else and I said well if you
want to bet on the game let's do it
whatever you want a gun got hurt so it
seemed true but we did put a bet on it I
don't we the paid off
is any legal I just said they're super
balls I know what it was and here's what
happened story is that we're on the 18th
hole and the whole match is coming down
to the 18 now John Elway has got nerves
of steel and of course he had a lot of
money so he always declared what we were
going to play for he didn't even ask me
well let's do this we could this
everything's automatic play you ever
just I'm going to lose a fortune if I
play bad but we're on the 18th hole Dan
Marino I just got a new set of clubs
Cobras big thing got him from Greg
Norman playing Cobras he swings the
driver on the 18th hole as he kits ready
hit the ball the club head breaks before
he hits the ball swings and misses the
club head flies a hundred yards out and
to the left and goes into the water and
he he goes he stayed up looking around
going oh oh oh I said I said the club
head broke you know we're kind of
laughing he goes well ok and I said hey
look I don't care what you do
your ass is hitting too right now and
that started an argument we still in the
tee box for 10 minutes and argued
finally he said but at the westin that's
where he lived and Randy he goes man
I've run the West I make the rules and
I'm gonna say I'm teeing off one well
whatever it was great me a lot of fun
playing golf can you imagine that I
can't that's all that's the first time
I've heard you tell that story actual 18
year old Tiger and Tiger was Jimmy
Roberts called me they were playing at
that course now many you know 25 years
later and asked about the story says
Tiger told his story is this true and I
said oh god it was he goes he couldn't
get over how y'all talked and treated
each other what was poor mark rippin
doing here because he seemed like he was
kind of quiet nicer than you guys
Oh what do you mean big rip first off
you hundred miles right and you know he
was the exact opposite of what you
thought so he was great
the golf course that's awesome oh my
gosh first off I'd sit turncoat damn he
plays quarterback I mean he's a giant
yeah he's such a big thick man oh my god
gosh he's a giant and I'm telling you
he'd hit that thing and it just seemed
coho I'm not gonna watch anymore
you know I thought I got hit it pretty
far but he was blown about John Elway me
and Dan Marino you know twenty and
thirty yards like there's nothing still
who won the hole who won hole 18 oh we
did okay me and Mark Ripon coming down
the great John Elway and Dan Marino oh
that's great at the time they had no
super balls and you guys had three if
it's right in hey Mark it's the 18th
hole it really means a lot
hmm you know some people choke and all
right so the battle today Phil what your
son is a ram and I am a Colt who would
you like to hear from first I'll judges
choice you're a Colt and gold and your
sons are you like the gun Colt or euro
he's like an Indianapolis calling course
ya know I knew that I was just kind of
yeah I'm not quite that you know Bob
also said malt liquor call 45 but it's
cold yes malt liquor loved I used to I
loved it did you that was 45 malt liquor
man give on those big cans my god it's
all you needed all you needed some Cobra
sticks because I gotta hear this
perfect big fell hi I'm occult I just
like to say I know that you guys are
height weight speed rams weigh anywhere
between 99 and 350 I mean we come out
the womb and at our least we're like
this by yourself leave my name out of
your mouth
also big fella have you seen the legs
and ass of a cult weird si Quan Barclay
of equine we are a say Quine the RAM the
animals name is their entire fight
strategy Ram you are a one-trick fighter
for word that is it every mr. Ram that
is a kick to the back of your tiny neck
we
kick we bite we stomp welcome to the big
leagues pal and just so you know in the
wild Colts are driven from their herds
at the age of one or two they join other
Colts in what is called a bachelor herd
and when there's a bunch it's called a
rape we are a rake of Bachelor Colts we
are an angry Vegas trip of young horses
ready to stomp you out we work well as a
team
Rams you just button to each other your
ain't going anywhere
you know do you do you guys like have a
research group that does this stuff for
you no we do it ourselves
yeah I go safe yet somebody doing it for
you should fire them mr. Ram go for it
all right that was a good argument it
was thank you well I mean first of all
you're a cult you're a baby horse
I mean horses are scared of the wind
okay that's the first you ever been
around a horse I mean you can literally
clap loud and they could go and run away
like you're right still degrees you grew
up in a farming knows what a Colts like
okay Rams talk about yeah a little
stumpy you're right but you want to talk
about power packed in power that like
you said can wake a male Ram which is
what I am a male Ram okay I can be
anywhere from 250 to 320 pounds you're
like a third I can jump my broad jumps
better than anybody that was in the NFL
Combine this year better than I am
amazing and I have great ability and
balance to run on different terrains I
can go higher up in the mountains than
any other animal except for one in the
whole world and my speed and power
well I'm like [ __ ] Ronnie lot coming
at you that's it's scary and you're not
gonna be able to do anything I mean
nothing I mean maybe you go and throw a
kick out there by like what - my RAM
head
- you're facing that's gonna hurt under
your little cauliflower dome I have 50
pound RAM raisin on the side here face
if I hit you on the side it's just
night-night horsey good night I don't
feel good about yeah good yeah you
shouldn't feel good at them that's all I
got
I didn't like was before Chris even went
Phil when that wasn't bad at him but
I'll tell you why you were wrong no but
now you've made me lose my train of
thought but that was clearly an ass
woman whoo that was an ass whippin today
I'm sorry Adam is that cold you cold and
you go boo they go crying and jumping
and run away have you danced in here and
you're gonna get a ram
you know never like when you know I was
growing up I don't my brothers and my
dad said look you be getting the fight
don't ever fight somebody that doesn't
worry about winning and losing because
he just wants to fight because he likes
the action those are the ones you got to
be afraid of right so that RAM he likes
action you kick him in the face
do you know that's goal Gibbs I mean
it's it's meant to take punishment right
take some the face he goes yummy he's go
that's pretty good felt good have you
ever fought a horse or a ram personally
no I never fought her Ram but have you
ever gotten to it like a fight with a
horse like a little tussle
slapped it around a little what happens
he threw me off that that and hearing
that dad's story about his newspaper
route when he had the dog chasing him
the one time my oldest brother Dominic
deliver papers and I was on one side of
the street he go give it to the next
three houses okay and I'm walking along
you know it's about 5:30 in the morning
darker and Hill scared to death and I
knew this house had a dog a basset hound
and that son of a gun would come out in
sorts and he'd get right up next to me I
was scared and I finally y'all Dominic
and Dominic my brother who you have to
meet him yeah I'll try to explain it
exist anymore I'll explain them off to
the air but Dominic comes running across
the street full speed
and kicks the dog and I was classmates
with the the kid who owned the garden on
the dog the green God just forgot the
name I must say not the Greenberg's but
whatever and he kills the dog would even
talk dead on the one cake yeah well my
god my brother is could really run and
he's older yards full speed and delivers
a kick and dog just goes wolf Lance ever
saw the dog I don't think that story was
gonna go that way yeah I thought you
read tell me the story about a dog
chasing Phil the dog chased him a few
times before that and I think that was
you know back then could run free
sometimes I had one last stupid story
but I was always here to this one house
he had a big German Shepherd and that
you know they got I try to sneak up to
the house to put the paper on the porch
from work he could always hear and he
come running around and get right up
next to me and I was like oh my gosh and
finally one day he got so close to me I
rare back and punched him right in the
face what you know dogs weren't chained
up they ran loose yeah that's crazy
that was crazy you can never do that out
of yeah you need to get arrested now if
you let your dogs run this you know the
Green Wells I remembered her name the
green well I apologize for the Sims
family to the green well they never said
a word to me though in school so I can't
home well they're gonna bring this up
and I don't know what happened to the
dog he might die just maybe put him in
the house for the rest of his life
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's got so many stories I just have to
get him on story though his dog and he
bothered me so my dog kicked him but he
died I think the dog had so many he
didn't get into some of the preface of
the story which was that it had happened
a few times I believe before that to
where he had had a guy climb up
Vence and stay on the fence until
someone came and helped him and his
oldest brother Dominic who he said they
don't make people like that anymore
yeah they probably don't he is he is
like when I say crazy sinners he is the
craziest of sins like he is Jean oh he's
got your debt your grandfather's Jean if
like pulling out his own T exactly and
like they're just the crudeness the
honesty of me the a few things one I
love the fact that you and your dad are
doing mascot battles when there's
animals involved because your dad has so
many interactions with these animals
over his life yeah - we're tapping into
this Kentucky part of your dad right
that is absurd yeah and it is crazy
we everyone knows about Phil Simms once
he gets to New York but there's a
southern Kentucky part yes that I can't
even I don't know where it's gonna go I
know I know we haven't has he told the
story yet about his father taking all
his teeth out of his mouth told this
time today
yeah yes question yes boys you think
your dad the fact that he was playing
ping pong today means something about
how he's feeling like would he normally
be playing ping pong on a random
Wednesday afternoon you're definitely on
the same but he's just he's he's got
nothing to do yep he is the ultimate
competitor he's the ultimate immediate
competitor definitely he's psycho
like he is definitely good you're gonna
go downstairs in the garage and hit some
man I want him thinking about good you
need to realize this - yeah you're gonna
need to be the most focus you've ever
been in your life oh I will this he will
seize any moment he's a game is gonna be
he's really good I think it's gonna be a
very even matchup I really do
I've seen you play enough to know you
are really good - yeah yeah it's gonna
be just about you control because he's
just gonna try to rattle you and be so
loud and crude he's just hoping it'll
mess you up a little to where he can
steal two or three points gonna be good
yeah so steer a call so speaking of the
goats yeah Blake bortles hmm Andrew
Norwell the big signing for the
Jacksonville Jaguars came out and said
quote Blake bortles is
one of the best I've ever been around
which is the biggest insult to Cam
Newton that I've ever heard of my entire
life well that maybe he's talking as a
person we're right we don't know what
he's best I've ever it's like it's like
when you go back to all the quotes when
they got reassigned like you said then
right when you get reassigned nobody
talked about his play everybody was like
he's a great leader he's awesome in the
locker room I think that he's trying to
say quote wrong I fit I think that's the
way I'm taking it yes
I don't think a lineman would even make
that kind of comment about a quarterback
at that point Blake bortles again where
I always will tell you and you guys know
I will always feel guilty I know the
guys good dude yeah everybody says that
everybody that's where I do it you
wouldn't go and say he's like the best
quarterback in the AFC South and should
be like number 50 in the top 100 you
wouldn't say that no somebody did really
yeah let's make sure my laptop's on this
is James Jones when asked which AFC
South quarterback will be revealed the
top 50 David Carr already says to Sean
Watson here's James Jones on Blake
bortles Blake bortles okay and I say
Blake bortles because Watson only place
David Carr has to audibly say because
he's smiling so big I'm not laughing at
you Blake
here's the rest of James Jones six games
this guy was in the AFC Championship
game beat a buffalo defense that's very
good beater Pittsburgh defense that was
very good went into New England and
almost pulled that one out and I am
saying Blake bortles Kadem can I and
then they go on to try and talk but
there's really no talking so the main
thing that I'd like to do for everybody
out there is all right so AFC
championship game hold on before we get
into this
do you know someone out there that thing
said Blake bortles is good do they not
realize that he was on the most talented
team in the NFL well guess what in 94
years we're here to help right for the
low price of nothing your loved one can
listen to The Sims and Lefko podcast and
realize the air in their ways please
reach out to James Jones his Twitter
handle is at eight nine Jones and TAF
and let him know that Sims and Lefko is
here to help him that's eight nine Jones
and TAF remember never let your friends
go full bortles this has been a message
from Sims and lefke you never go full
bortles never go for portals let's see
this is why context matters in these
conversations right as soon as you hear
someone give Blake bortles credit for
anything on that Jaguar steam about
where they go to or wins he's a winner
I'm just gonna say this I can never
listen to another piece of James Jones
target I just tell theirs how about
Rogers or anybody it's if you're that
separate from reality I just can't talk
to you anymore
it does it's that's questionable there's
no doubt about it it makes makes me
wonder a lot there is and you know again
the points are what they're bad he
talked about the team right the point so
everything was t Merlyn o beat a good
buffalo defense you mean with that 12
423 performance for 87 yards and they
scored 10 points
James Ainge and let's not forget that
the nine incompletions were like we
would like left go you would have
completed him so that to be the first
issue then you go to the pittsburgh game
i mean we've said this a million times
but come on there was twenty eight to
seven and he was seven for 14 for 83
yards and no touch now don't need to
explain i know this was more of a
message to people out there i know if
you're facing tough times Sims and left
go on so the question was never let your
arms of the name
yeah go for bortles they were they were
doing their stupid I know but they were
happy please what correc was going to be
in the top 50 it was there was so
there's an AFC Court at AFC South
quarterback being revealed between 50
and 60 which one is it Mariota had he
gone already no damn
so they he chose bortles had that three
guys he he didn't even he was perfect
Eric deshaun Watson it was two Shola
okay how does I say even the Andrew Luck
if he hasn't played in three years I'm
still with guy he's good the guy had
pick over that all right so that was
unreal i when I heard that speaking of
former teammate Aaron Rodgers quick
contract updates story Roger sees Thomas
to me trough in the airport the Super
Bowl says look we don't know each other
that well but get this deal done with
Matt first so I can get on with my life
still waiting on the Rodgers contract I
think the most interesting contract
situation that no one's talking about is
Zack Martin mmm you're right it's been
totally lost in the shuffle
right now there's no timetable for a
deadline yeah there's no progress this
one could be a big time battle because
no player got complimented more by their
ownership than Zack Martin right talking
about him being a hall-of-famer talked
about him being like Larry Allen and now
he's sitting there he's got to get paid
he's 27 so he's not the 25 year old
second contract right and they are gonna
have to pay him a ton and guards are
getting paid a ton look at what Norwell
got but Jacksonville look what Pugh got
in Arizona
look what Weston Richburg got with San
Francisco Zack Martin is gonna get cut
bigger than Colette Co semele money
definitely in Dallas
yes and they're already up against if
they are up against it that's the
problem but to me it's a guy that's been
publicly supported by the franchise and
now you're not budging totally the team
success started as soon as he got there
I mean right it's when they became
you're like oh this offensive line that
went from being good to the best often
slime we've seen since the Cowboys in
the early 90s we've seen tyrants Smith
miss games but not Zack Martin no I know
yes I think you're right in this good
call by heralded we need to talk more
because I think Zack Martin's contract
situation could get real test yes and
the fact that Zack Martin is is one of
the 20 best players in football really I
mean I know it's a garden it
hard to quantify that but he's without a
doubt been the best guard in football
the last few years and he's really on
pace as far right now is one of the best
guards we've seen in the sport and yes
he's better than Andrew nor well he's
better than Kevin Zeidler you talked
about Cole heo somali yeah i mean nor
balls getting 13 three a year is idlers
getting 12 a year it's a male he's
getting eleven point seven should be
asking for 15 basically I think that's
exactly right and I don't know how
Dallas is gonna make all this work I'm
really interested to see what Dallas
does here because you also have DeMarcus
Lawrence you got dak coming up on the
horizon Zeke you got Zeke after that
Travis federic they already pay so it's
it's gonna be they're gonna have to
really work some magic I know I'm not
you know I'm very curious especially
boys are curious it's gonna be
interesting
alright so what if I told you that
LeBron James was in a contract year and
he wasn't getting what he wanted so he
went and he created a rap song in which
he said they're not paying me the right
amount of money they're two-faced
they're lying to me they're making me
out to be the bad guy would you think
that that would be a story that we
talked about for a long time I mean if
LeBron James says it I mean I think
people would take the streets with
pitchforks and be like we gotta kill
this guy what about what about Russell
Westbrook like it wasa Westbrook came
out and made a rap song and was like oh
I'm not getting paid what a loose cannon
he is I mean this is this is why I can't
work on the court he gotta take 40 shots
he's a loose cannon
Le'Veon Bell did that yeah and no one's
talking about it Le'Veon Bell put out a
rap song saying those things and the
only thing we're saying right now is
Le'Veon Bell says he needs more money no
one's listening to it well because we've
kind of become the the podcast that
plays rappers music here is target by
levy on bail one I need you to think is
he better than Cole Beasley here we go
wonder why they treat me like the bag so
that's the first verse good one Josh
first heard he goes he's really passed
Josh didn't like it at all well I'll say
this where Col Beasley is the event he
didn't use the Machine the the autotune
autotune right yeah I don't think it was
heart I don't think it was bad I just
looked like Ray wasn't good it wasn't
good it wasn't good it wasn't Arian
Foster I just know it was not a bad look
at it and I go this guy is openly
talking about his contracts in a rap
song and I don't think it's being
discussed enough he says he wants to be
paid 17 million dollars they're telling
me is not the best team they're saying
he's out of shape they're saying he's
saying different things to his face and
then he comes in a little bit later and
he says this and I don't know what he's
talking about
[Music]
he says he goes everyone's worried about
the drug test I never failed right
that's on me if you got pulled over they
should be worried about the P
performance-enhancing drugs peds is he
calling somebody else out there right
now that someone else is on peds you're
worried about my drug test that never
happened but you should be worried about
the peds probably can we hear that again
can I get that part one more time yeah I
would like to I heard the peds that
couldn't quite figure out that's the
[ __ ] you gotta worry about the cheaters
yes of course that's what he's saying
yes so I think it's just more about the
NFL yeah I think I think that he's a top
running back I do not think he's a top
rapper in the NFL but I just think it's
crazy that this is a star in the NFL
that's openly saying all this and it's
not being talked about no it's it's not
the Thunder are lying to me they're
talking bad they're telling me to my
face that I'm not the best of my
position I think it is I think I should
be getting paid this much they actually
tagged me and I feel like a target I
know I think it is we think pieces it's
it's the it's the the the fact that the
NBA has an individuality in the NFL is
just not about that the fanbase doesn't
really focus on that a whole lot as a
whole I know it's cool I will say this
as much as I love love me on bell 17 a
year I just I do think he's got to come
down a hair I got it I do listen you
can't sit here and tell me that he's
worth double-a Devonta Freeman are
LeSean McCoy they're making am i if I'm
arguing for him I go in chronically
under pain I get I get the art because I
would say that OC you wanted to get what
14 so you think that he's won him I can
understand not bring him out right now I
get under understand him wanting his
worth but yeah I do think that market
price is part of this conversation
so here so he in his mind you're telling
me that his team in Antonio Brown is
worth 33% more than him I I don't think
it necessarily
no not in my eyes but in the nfl's eyes
yes yes yes I think if he realistically
was asking for a 14 a year 15 a year I
could deal with that even though I'm
still go man that's a lot more than
anybody else out there is making I
understand his argument about being the
receiver and the running back and doing
all those things and he certainly is
special I'm just saying
being around the NFL as long as I've had
when the whole NFL guys are making 6
million 5 million 8 million
Le'Veon Bell isn't that much better for
me to go well he deserves double yeah
double no as we've always said as the
players podcast we want levian to hold
out because he needs to set the market
for the running backs yeah required of
the best running backs to hold out
because they are the most disrespected
position in the entire sport and that
look maybe he ends up being a Kirk
Cousins yeah they're not gonna want to
tag him a third time because then he's
gonna be in the 20s next year right and
these could hit free agency and it's
gonna be the rare case where a 28 year
old prime time position player is
hitting the market without his team
having leverage yeah that's what I think
is gonna happen
I think levian plays this year they're
gonna try and tag him again
and all of a sudden it's an open race
maybe he gets more guaranteed money and
he changes contracts for running yeah
don't play don't so do anything until
you got to these are the rules that are
set forth so I mean all of that I'm like
Odell I don't want to see you out there
until you get the long term money long
term security I will disagree with you
the fact that I don't think he gets the
third franchise tag I think that will
draw the line where they're gonna look
at it go where we're not gonna let so I
said with Kirk Cousins oh they're not
gonna give the third guy so I'll get out
there I got your boy Brandon Marshall
sign with the seal for him I think
that's a good spot for is it I do I
haven't talked to him I know he had gone
out there and all that I mean Marshalls
gonna has played with some incredible
storylines incredible storylines I mean
yes we know that and I really think this
is the perfect type of mix for him as
far as what he wants to do as a player
and what he can do to contribute to a
team and he can be a big receiver on a
team that wrote like runs a lot so it's
a little bit more improvisational rate
at back shoulder throws and things like
that see that's where like Brandon
probably messed up in his signing with
the Jaya's like Eli Manning's not that
kind of quarterback
he's not trying to make power throws
right to where all of me fit in a cover
to hole ball and throw a laser in there
so I can use a size to go up again or
the back shoulder ball whatever man
that's not Eli Manning's game where
Russell Wilson if he sees one on one
like that he will do that we saw that
with Jimmy Graham in the last few years
so it's time to go out of left go field
let's go out to left go random stories
and conspiracies that I'm seeing or
things I think you need to be aware of
and we're gonna start off first with the
new Russia is a hoax well that's a big
conspiracy being floated out there just
so you know it's a hoax no it's always
global warming he's complained about the
weather at Giants Stadium before like
about how the I don't question the
weather says the same as bad as when it
I used to play and I want to be like
yeah well first of all dad get your
right because in November I used to wear
snow suits to your games but I've said
this to them all the time I go dad its
global I don't know whatever it is it's
just not as bad that's great that was
out of Sims Stadium sorry that was great
no your dad makes me laugh first one is
there's an attack on a position in the
NFL right now and I think we need to
address it and that position is
equipment men okay first we saw Brady
the pumper the deflator those guys still
haven't heard from them now
they're disappeared we don't know where
they are Siberia Siberia
they've gone it's amazing now the New
York Giants that's right
ed and Joe Skiba and ed Wagner all of
whom were with the Giants for two-plus
decades fired after the Eli Manning
scandal Wagner was with the Giants since
I was a little boy more than 40 years
these guys took the fall completely for
the Eli Manning memorabilia scandal so
Eli goes hey I don't feel like giving up
the game ball can you get one that looks
like it and I'll sign that and they're
the ones getting they get fired
apparently in some text between Joe and
Ed the two schemes yeah this is what got
them fired Joe apparently texts and
wanted to get more money and said or
quote I'll tell the whole [ __ ] world
truth I don't fire people that save
they're gonna tell the whole [ __ ]
world the truth now I'd like to get the
schemas in here for an interview well
yeah but they I'm the Giants who know
they disappear like the Patriots
everybody there's probably an NDA
they're gonna be paid for the next 20
years by the Giants pretty much what's
imagine doing so is that the new trend
in the NFL is the magical disappearing
equipment men they're the real
storytellers huh well they know
everything they know everything they
really do yeah they get all the dirt you
get the dirt from the players the
coaches damn even the secretaries feel
comfortable telling them crap so they're
just walking around walking around hey
can I have an extra t-shirt I'm gonna go
work out so there's always little things
like that it's I don't know the ski buzz
real well okay I know who they are I
mean it's a shame to see them fired
Eddie Wagner is the one that got me
legend legend I mean man Eddie Wagner do
you know how many times he cussed me out
as a little kid because I took too many
pieces of gun from gum from the players
business oh my gosh because I was like
man free gum juicy-fruit Doublemint
Spearman let me try 20 of each and I
like to shove them in my pocket then
he'd come around the corner in the
locker room I everybody there for the
[ __ ] Flyers
just take two or three that's how I used
to yell at me but not it sucks yeah it
sucks I don't know I don't really know
them I mean maybe him maybe there's no I
can't imagine I just wanna know I feel
bad I do feel bad it go go back to my
original thought with this whole thing
is why is Eli Manning worried about an
extra million dollar sign in helmets or
footballs anyways gosh damn I mean you
got so much money you can't even spend
it all what does that matter I
understand that's maybe a shallow
cattleman it's not when you have a
hundred eighty million in the bank do
you really need the extra nine hundred
thousand to make a difference in life so
just something that'll of go field be
careful of the disappearing equipment
men they hold all the secrets second
thing there is an analytics arms race
going on in the NFL first I'd like to
say this if there's someone out there
that you know and I might be sitting
next to him right now that says
analytics will never work in the NFL
statistics are just too hard to come by
those
not the statistics that we're talking
about right there's an analytics out
there that is changing the game
the Broncos brought Sam hinkie in former
GM of the Philadelphia 76ers and a
leader of the trust the process movement
to meet with Elway and other team
executives and Scouts a lot of people
heard this story and they went are the
Broncos gonna start tanking for draft
picks as though that was the only thing
that Sam hinkie taught them about no the
main reason they brought him in the
Broncos like every team in the NFL have
a ton of data but they don't know what
to do with it
this is what's happening right now in
the analytics movement everybody is
charting everything but they don't know
what the data means and that's why
people like hinky are so important the
main focuses he talked about player
evaluation in game situations salary
capping contract decisions and the one
that's causing a lot of attention
training and rehab Mitch tani the
Broncos director of football analytics
said if we do some one-off research that
doesn't make sense that doesn't do
anybody good it needs to be applicable
so before you say analytics don't work
in football realize that how we Roseman
the GM the Eagles is a leader in the NFL
in using them yeah I watched an
interview what do you think yeah I mean
I watched an interview at a conference
it was at the Wharton School of Business
in Philadelphia and he said this about
spatial analytics this is when they
charred a guy they see how far he runs
and where he goes and all that stuff
when we have the player tracking at the
beginning of the season and we can track
it through the course of the year we can
be proactive to understand how their
bodies are reacting and maybe get them
out of harm's way before they're injured
this is a big deal for us that we're
focusing on we use this everything we do
before we sign a free agent we have our
sports scientists look at how the gait
of the player is to see if there's
anything that may give us a heads up on
a decline we'll go through the NFL
Combine and separately look at our guys
that are training our staffs he talked
about there's so much analytics right
now in tracking the movement of humans
that play football but it's a race to
figuring out how do we use this
information where can we actually get
correlation between is if they run the
most do they get injured the most if the
run a certain way do they get injured
the most there is an analytics race in
the NFL and I think part of it's because
half the NFL said that analytics aren't
real yeah
so in a league where you're always
trying to find an edge this is the
biggest edge whoever figures out that
data first wins yeah who there's a lot
there it's a lot to digest um that's why
it's out of love no fee the first thing
I would say is analytics have always
gone on in the NFL always they were all
way I mean how do you think New England
hasn't dominated for the last 17 years
just by Bill going I've got a gut
feeling let's go with this right so
analytics go on I think where the
conversation got skewed in the NFL was
the Shashi brown thing because that
became a different part of analytics
that weren't involved with the NFL
necessarily which I do think became more
stat based right and then people going
or you're taking stats from college and
there's so many variables that affect
those stats I don't see how that's gonna
work and I think that's why some draft
picks were missed there and Cleveland
because the the the formula itself had
no relevance to football on the field in
the NFL now yes our team's gonna
continue to improve their analytics
certainly yes there's more information
out there now than ever especially with
like things like PFF and most teams have
PFF contracts is referring I hear from
my coaching friends more than anything I
don't really have to make the breakdowns
of film anymore I can just watch it so
that change coaches oh that's the other
the other analytics I think it really is
is putting sensors on humans and just
studying their movements sure now now
now we're into some really in-depth we
are and but but like I've always told
both you that the NFL has been light
years behind in these categories right
whether it's physical because I just
think it was like it's an old-school
mentality in the NFL it's rub some dirt
on it put some ice on it and let's suck
it up and we'll see if you can go next
week and there wasn't that it wasn't
viewed as such a smart business move but
I think people are starting to realize
when how heroes when wins a Super Bowl
right like we've talked about in the
copycat league all of a sudden you go
that's a GM that not only has not
coached he has not played we could
actually win with someone thinking like
that yes I mean analytics again you know
there's gonna be it's about how you use
it right so I'll take you doing a little
variance I had a New England at one
point where I was about to have to do
this project but things change and I
didn't have to do the project but they
basically wanted me to like look at the
20 best defensive tackles in football
and come up with all the variables of
what made them good and some of their
weaknesses right so that's already going
on so again that's where I go to you
with the certain things like when we
talk about New England and I had a
grading scale for the position the
analytics said some of the variables
that needed to be essential for me to
actually go this guy could play on the
New England Patriots team and that is
part of the analytics like I've talked
about with the quarterback thing have to
be a certain height a certain weight
certain hand size Wonderlic defensive
tackle gosh I can't remember off the top
of my head but you know it was it was
like gosh I can't I can I really
couldn't even tell you it was like to 95
or above certain arm lengths right
because the defensive tackle for New
England it's really the five technique
in a lot of ways too so we were looking
at those type of things arm length where
they're cut in the waist all those type
of things we're gonna play into whatever
the bench press is you know numbers that
we might have seen from his college
squat everything all those things that
play into it to go is there some common
ground here yeah that we're finding
correlation from these guys and that is
going on in there that's all but the
information the first thing I thought
when I read this about Denver and I
thought about how your Roseman was
that's how incredible Belichick is is
that he's probably internally processing
all of this and then I think about the
guy who I saw in the mall who was the GM
Oh NICUs area Nick Caesarea and I go I I
would love to know what modules and
systems he's running to get tests on
people and then I think about somebody
like Gruden and I go he's acting from
the gut Jon Gruden is probably not yes
certainly I'm probably going like your
numbers you've been on the football
field no like that's why the NFL's craze
it it's crazy and it seemed you're right
there there are teams that can admit
that the numbers are there and there are
teams that are gonna act like they're
not and they will get passed yeah that's
what's gonna happen yeah last out of
left go field is please help Aaron
Rodgers Jason Waddell the state journal
Dovan to the Packers playbook remodeling
this is a big story that we're all
excited about the Green Bay Packers are
scrubbing it they're starting from page
one and there's some good stuff yeah
there's a lot of stuff that I read that
I don't like first I
love that they're making the playbook a
group effort I think that what I learned
from the Eagles last year was having
defillippo
and Reich and Peterson is it created an
open conversation and a competition and
Mike gros got in there and so to do
Staley and I thought that that ended up
being great however here is who is in
the room for the Packers tell me if I'm
wrong Joe Philbin
yeah we're not that excited he's been
there before right Jim Hossler is their
passing game coordinator he was the
Colts tight ends coach from last year
last time he was an offensive
coordinator was in San Francisco in 2007
and I have read all the reviews and it
didn't go well and Frank Cignetti jr.
who was the quarterbacks coach under Ben
McAdoo and the Giants these are all
former McCarthy protegees these are all
people that have worked under McCarthy
before these are not different ideas
these are not new play books they're
people that were under McCarthy when
other places worked with other people
and are coming back I wanted them to be
completely original
these are retreads the article made it
seem like the new additions were more
concerned with learning the updated
McCarthy offense than adding scheme
we're trying to catch up a lot of this
offense has changed Oh
McCarthy this is the first one there are
two comments that scare me this one's
from hustler yeah quote it's not going
to change drastically the evolution has
been because of the greatness of the
quarterback it really won't look any
different from the eye because it's how
the quarterback plays which has been my
fear with Aaron Rodgers he's admitting
that the offense is the same but Aaron
Rodgers carries us and it's not gonna be
different
because it's gonna be on Aaron Rodgers
I'm getting convulsions number two and
the one that really upset me was from
Joe Philly's complaint he was talking
about how at this time they're spending
a lot of time making sure that their
formation names are similar quote we
don't have to sit around and call it oh
that's viking right because we're in
minnesota and the next week it's st.
Louis left even though I guess st. Louis
doesn't have a team anymore he started
it with even though I guess
as though maybe they will come back to
st. Louis and maybe you guys think
they're in LA but they're actually still
the st. Louis Rams Joe Philbin is
bringing ideas when he doesn't even
remember half the time that there isn't
a football team in st. Louis right so
basically what he's saying there is
there's simplified certain things right
there's no reason because what I needed
from the Packers office is more
simplification I know I know which you
know what basically what he's saying
there is like we have the same formation
right but when we have two tight ends
and two receivers in the game we call it
st. Louis and when we have three
receivers and one tight end of the game
we call it Minnesota even though it's
the same exact formation so that's what
he's telling you there so that's the
brain Buster's these guys are doing
right now like I did I read into that
too much no you're you're spot-on broski
I just read these articles because I go
I want to know what's happen with the
Packers office I think this is my fear a
point you made about no new ideas okay
that's the first thing you're right
these are all retreads of McCarthy so
they're all gonna bring back the same
ideas josh is taking a big breath
because he's had enough of this podcast
but the other thing - I mean is it
encouraging to know that they are making
changes hey listen ski chains certainly
that they realize there are things have
to be changed but yeah I'm not expecting
anything drastic I know it's it's it's
within the scope of their knowledge
right and I don't think there's a whole
lot out there other than that that
they've gotten to see or be a part of so
the scope of their knowledge is West
Coast basic [ __ ] sorry yeah that's
fine do I think that these coaches that
Philbin and Hossler and Cignetti and
Cignetti
went to places and and maybe adapted and
learned some more plays more
philosophies absolutely but I just need
people to admit that as human beings we
come in with our natural bias and what
we've learned in the past is our roots
and as we go we adapt our roots but
realize that all these guys are coming
back with the same adapted roots exactly
all gonna go back to the new ideas here
and there exactly right but nothing
nothing
I was hoping that by the Packers not
making the playoffs and the realization
of how reliant they were on Aaron
Rodgers they bring in a fresh start
yeah and we ain't get no you're not
getting it and then I thought we were
getting paid
biggest things to me when I go to Green
Bay and you know again it's always like
you know
WW nd what would New England do I think
that's the standard you should be held
by you know this is the one thing I look
at and I think a lot of people in the
NFL missed this and this is where Green
Bay and like Seattle and some of those
boring offenses we've looked at over the
last year's they thrive on a certain
scheme that New England doesn't even do
and I want to be like damn don't you
watch them which is really the 3-step
drop back pass game it does not exist in
New England really if mu and I went back
there and watched all the tape from New
England last year we would see very few
slant flat or double slant they don't
run really run the three-step drop back
pass game in fact when they throw it
short most of the times it's like the
third read let me look into the two guys
on the right ones running the post the
other ones are in a deep corner and now
Edelman's coming across the middle at
five or six and a half steps whose took
in like a you know I did a jerk route
and where he faked like he was gonna go
back out the other way then he came up
house and he was Brady's third read so
that would be the issue I would look at
first of all when you are always in the
three-step drop game right defensive
linemen know oh let me get my hands up
let me get back the ball down right
so that becomes one thing defensive
coordinators start to go well generally
they throw the ball right here in these
regions so let's just stay in those
regions and make the picture cloudy for
Rodgers and then what happens to the
picture is cloudy for Rogers and he pump
fakes and does see no seventh whirley's
and then has to find somebody open
that's where they dropped the ball
you know like when we ran when I was in
New England and we ran you know slant
with a flat route I mean that was
something like I was like oh wow like
Josh must have really seen something on
film this week to even call this like we
don't this isn't even the play the game
plan yeah and then places like new you
know we talked about Seattle and Green
Bay
it's the meat and potatoes it's what
with you R'lyeh it's a big play let's go
to Slainte flat and then they go damn
why didn't it work why wasn't nobody
open because it's a shouldn't event such
a thing no time you've run the play this
year I hope I hope that it's all I hope
they're they're putting up some smoke
screens I'm all I'm doing is reading
can't read too much line around number
12
just give them
he just needs a few curveballs some
screens here and there
I just he'll be fine I just want some
new formation movement before the snack
can happen and some details alright so
that was a long but fun what do you
think about the new digs
I love the new digs I want to be able to
look at you guys and talk to you we've
never looked at each other like that in
the old conference room we did I was a
little interrupting Cal you're horrible
today no so much so that just wrote me a
note that says I'm you're interrupting
my line guys thank you so much as always
this is gonna be our new home so again
if you have stuff that you want to send
us anything
16:33 Broadway second floor just title
it Sims and left go we'll open it on the
pot I think it'll be great time but we
appreciate it thank you for engaging
with us with us on all social media at
Sims and left over that's Instagram or
Twitter or whether that's the iTunes
comments or the reddit which I go on
there when I'm on the toilet and really
enjoy what you guys are going on right
but next week I have no idea but I know
we're back here we're back and it's
gonna be great and what's next week you
might be wearing some things oh yeah
coming may be swag for Sims peace out
homies for federic good evening
everybody and for the lef koe man
we will holla at you later enjoy your
weekend
enjoy the NFL the playas podcast signing
out